nigeria's defense ministry has confirmed
that suspected
islamist militants killed 71 soldiers
near the border with mali
a nighttime ambush on a military camp in
innate's in the southwest also wounded
12 soldiers
and left several more missing the
so-called islamic state has long been
active in the area
and dw reporter tommy oladipo has been
looking into this story for us he's with
us here in studio hi tommy
what more can you tell us about this
attack well uh it's reported from the
defense ministry that
they say hundreds of attackers came to
this camp that was on tuesday
hundreds of them came with gunfire with
mortars shells even suicide car bombs
and stormed the camp
and the fighting went on for about three
hours before the defense ministry says
the attackers then fled across the
nearby border to mali so this is this is
believed to be the largest or
the deadliest attack so far on nigerian
troops
we mentioned that the so-called islamic
state is present in this area
are they behind this attack well we
don't know yet we'll find out
soon this is the kind of attack
especially one of this size that jihadi
groups tend to
to treasure and we'll hear something
from them
you know soon whether in form of a
statement or even sometimes a form of
a recording they tend to record these
attacks uh but the islamic state has
this growing presence
in the sahel not just in niger and when
people look at for example syria and
iraq and they assume
you know because the islamic state has
had a decline there then it's over
that's not the case in the sahel this is
a difficult place to govern
and it's a place where they will feel
like they can grow
they can breed and they can attack uh
targets in that region
so we're talking about a serious
security risk for the sahara region
can these nations cope these are poor
nations in the sahel they're they're
vast as well they're
vast territory difficult to govern and
they've been looking uh
to the outside world for help because
they've been struggling so we've seen
countries like france and the us send
thousands of troops
into the region to try and help france
in particular
has led the way uh it even lost a few 13
troops
recently in a helicopter collision
france then called a summit with some of
these nations these sahel nations and
said let's
find a new way forward but actually as a
result of this latest attack france has
cancelled
that so it's not just these poor nations
that are struggling to deal with a
threat
but even the bigger nations france and
the us as well are struggling what can
france and also europe germany in this
case do to help
well france and the france in particular
has been pressuring the rest of the
world
countries like germany and saying you
need to do more this is not just a local
problem they're saying it's a global
problem
and they want the international
community to get more involved
but the moment there's so much confusion
so many interventions
there isn't a sort of global cohesive
thought as to how to get
uh the security situation the sahel
sorted and that
is i think the sticking point at the
moment all right dw reporter tomi
oladipa
bringing us this story thank you so much
for joining us here in studio
you